ça va vous être à stresser non ça va pas
du tout franchement très content
[Musique]
ans
on
oh
[Musique]
à
et
ans
le motif je suis moi tu es juges rendue
qu'à ça va vous être adressée non ça va
pas du tout franchement très content non
pas du tout les bombes russie oui on va
donner
rendez-vous au général par contre genre
d'autoliv rien à faire un compliqué
ouais ça marche pas terminé a été ben
oui on sent un petit peu mais ça va rien
d'important
je suis père
[Musique]
bon
j'ai appelé j'ai eu tout de suite
quelqu'un qui m'a donné rendez vous
jeudi 7 et vendredi dernier on est
mercredi donc même pas une semaine quoi
léger le deuxième rendez vous est déjà
pris pour dans un mois pile après un
truc de moins à procéder quand même ça
va pas changé tant que ça en fait ombre
et dans la vie de tous les jours mais
mais quand même
effectivement
[Musique]
e
nous avons une stratégie complémentaire
à celle qui a été lancé avec le
vaccinodromes le centre de vaccination
le grand saut de vaccination à saint
denis au stade de france
être au plus proche de la population on
va vers les gens exactement comme on a
fait lorsque nous avons des pistes et
1000 personnes depuis juillet dernier
donc effectivement à saint point à
saint-ouen
notre stratégie est d'aller directement
vers les gens de les appeler de faire du
chirurgicale du précis d'où la nécessité
de travailler en de façon précise de
façon en dire encore une fois
chirurgicale de façon exhaustive avec
tous les élus locaux
un département comme le nôtre la seine
saint denis n'a pas le même n'est pas
impacté de la même façon pour des
raisons multifactorielle mais n'est pas
passé de la même façon qu'un autre
département au fin fond du centre de la
france c'est un point par exemple on est
au centre de la métropole
nous avons dix mille entreprises 4 5
kilomètres carrés énormément énormément
de brassage de population sur le plan
économique sur le plan sociologique
nous ne sommes pas nous ne sommes pas
exposés de la même façon qu'un autre
département
au delà des raisons socioculturelles qui
ont été évoqués sur problème de doses en
environnement anxiogène
effectivement on sait que lorsqu'on
regarde en seine-saint-denis il peut y
avoir un sujet de fracture numérique
problèmes d'accès avec les différentes
plateformes
on peut avoir un souci d'information
avec tous les fantasmes qui pourrait qu
aurait pu circuler sur les conséquences
négatives d'un vaccin et surtout le
problème de doses ont cessé ces trois
éléments
[Musique]
non